you tell a story of an SS soldier early
in the war world war ii in nazi-occupied
France in Paris where he grew up he
picked you up and hugged you and showed
you a picture of a boy
maybe not realizing that you were Jewish
not maybe certainly not so I told you
I'm from the Soviet Union that was
significantly impacted by the words well
and I'm Jewish as well what do you think
World War two taught us about human
psychology broadly well I think the the
only big surprise is the extermination
policy genocide by the German people
that's when you look back on it and you
know I think that's a major surprise
it's a surprise because it's a surprise
that they could do it it's a surprise
that they that enough people willingly
participated in that this is this is a
surprise
now it's no longer a surprise but it's
changed many people's views I think
about about human beings certainly for
me the Ackman trial in that teaches you
something because it's very clear that
if it could happen in Germany it could
happen anywhere it's not that the
Germans were special this could happen
anywhere so what do you think that is do
you think we're all capable of evil
we're all capable of cruelty I don't
think in those terms I think that what
is certainly possible is you can
dehumanize people so that there you
treat them not as people anymore but as
animals and the same way that you can
slaughter animals without feeling much
of anything it can the same and when you
feel that the I think the combination of
dehumanizing the other side and and
having uncontrolled power
over other people I think that doesn't
bring out the most generous aspect of
human nature so that Nazi soldier you
know he he was a good man I mean you
know and he was perfectly capable of
killing a lot of people and I'm sure he
did but what what did the Jewish people
mean to Nazis so what the dismissal of
Jewish as well worthy of again this is
surprising that it was so extreme but
it's not one thing in human nature I
don't want to call it evil but the
distinction between the in-group and the
out-group that is very basic
so that's built in the the loyalty and
affection towards in-group and the
willingness to dehumanize the out-group
that's that is in human nature and
that's that's what I think probably
didn't need the Holocaust to teach us
that but the Holocaust is is a very
sharp lesson of you know what can happen
to people and when the people can do so
the effect of the in group and the a
group you know that it's clear that
those were people you know you could you
could shoot them you could you know they
were not human they were not there was
no empathy or very very little empathy
left so occasionally you know they might
have been and and very quickly by the
way the empathy disappeared if there was
initially and the fact that everybody
around you was doing it that that
completely the group doing it and
everybody shooting Jews I think that
that makes it permissible now how much
you know whether it would it could
happen
in every culture or whether the Germans
were just particularly efficient
and undisciplined so they could give it
away with it that is a question it's an
interesting question are these artifacts
of history or is it human nature I think
that's really human nature you know you
put some people in a position of power
relative to other people and and then
they become as human become different
but in general and war outside of
concentration camps in World War two
it seems that war brings out darker
sides of human nature but also the
beautiful things about human nature well
no I mean but it what it brings out is
the loyalty among soldiers I mean it
brings out the bonding male bonding I
think is a very real thing that and that
happens and so and and there is a
student thrill to friendship and there
is certainly a certain thrill to
friendship under risk and to shared risk
and so people have very profound
emotions up to the point where it gets
so traumatic that that little is left
but
you